[Music]
you ever feel like you're being followed
[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna be
talking about the official trailer for
better call saul season six i'm gonna
break that down and we also have a
poster to talk about my initial reaction
to the trailer beyond just being hyped
that the final season is almost here is
that it's heavy it's dark and it has an
ominous feeling to it which it should
but i couldn't help to notice that there
is a real contrast to the early seasons
which i just recently rewatched it's
been a journey there's a ton of stuff in
here and i'll try to touch on it all
based on what's there i'm presuming most
of this is from the first few episodes
jimmy still has noticeable sunburn and
in that one shot lalo is still wearing
the same shirt he had on in the season 5
finale as far as spoilers if anything i
just mentioned sounds like something you
don't want to hear speculation about
then this is your chance to leave and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
better call soul has always had pretty
great posters and the one they put out
for season six is no exception you have
black and white gene slipping his arm
into a red jacket with the obvious
suggestion of him suiting up assault
goodman one last time it's funny because
after five seasons i tend to think of
him as jimmy more than saul at this
point but in the gene scenes we do see
him thinking about his time after the
name change and relating to that period
of his life there aren't any black and
white scenes in the trailer and there is
this anticipation that there's gonna be
a lot more of those in season six
possibly some full episodes so we got
this in that short teaser to keep gene
in the mix the trailer opens with a shot
of the el camino dining room this isn't
a place we've seen before and beyond the
nod to the name of the breaking bad
movie there isn't much context to say
what's happening here if we're thinking
these scenes are all from the early
episodes though then there are several
others that he's wearing the same suit
you see him with kim leaving the
apartment and this is where i first
noticed the sunburn he's carrying an
extra suit and kim is carrying the
world's second best lawyer mug which now
has a bullet hole in it as they leave in
a taxi you can see that the mug has been
thrown in the trash can and that feels
like a transition to whatever's coming
next for this couple there's also a shot
where we see marco's ring on jimmy's
hand then we see him walking into a
courtroom with the same suit and then
later sitting there in the dark by
himself he looks like he's waiting for
someone but i'm not sure what else to
make of it it's funny because when you
see the shot of marco's ring that makes
you think he's up to something but when
would you expect him not to be up to
something in this final season so it
doesn't really give much away quite a
few of the scenes in the trailer take
place in mexico we see the cousins
arrive at lala's hacienda after gus's
failed attempt to take him out we've
already seen a little bit of this from
when they teased the release date and
there's an aerial shot of the crime
scene where there are 12 body bags laid
out and you can see the cousins entering
the house inside the body bags would be
the men that gus hired and some of
lalo's staff there's a shot where you
see the cousins walk past the crashed
car and then later there's someone
firing a gun into the air in the same
place this all seems to be related to
nacho the second shot in the teaser is
him peeking out of a hiding place and he
has a tough go in almost every scene we
see here we see him running down a dirt
road which is probably the morning after
he left lalo's compound we'll see him
running towards a mexican hotel and then
just a ton of shots of him looking
scared pointing a gun jumping out of a
window running through a field and then
this one where you see one of the
cousins kick in the door at that same
hotel but it looks like from this shot
he's hiding outside with these two guns
in the front seat of a truck there's
another shot where he holds his nose and
then submerges himself underwater
somewhere dark it looks like a pipe or
something underground and you can't say
for sure but then there's this other
shot of gus where it looks like he's in
an underground tunnel and those two
things feel like they could be connected
so his situation looks desperate but
there might be a chance for him to get
back to the us for his girlfriends on
the other hand there's this shot of them
where they look scared as hell up
against the door and you can see someone
approaching this doesn't look good for
them they look terrified rather than
just being startled or something like
that because we do see mike in his house
actually most of the scenes we see with
mike are there but this doesn't look
like a reaction to him we do see that he
finds a safe in his place and he looks
inside you see some cash in those ids we
see those in his hand and that's a good
sign that maybe nacho is moving towards
making it out of there because again we
do see gus and victor driving in a van
and then we see mike standing outside of
that carrying a large bag and he says to
someone whatever happens next it's not
going to go down the way you think it is
so that comes at the end of the trailer
and it's sort of them talking to us as
the viewers saying that you don't know
what's going to happen in the final
season and it does hint at there being
hope for nacho but at the same time he
is a loose end for gus mike's carrying
his rifle he could just as easily be
going to shoot nacho and his father as
he is trying to help them it makes sense
for gus to want to get him out of mexico
because he wouldn't want him questioned
letting him go though mike certainly was
for this but didn't seem to have enough
influence to get gus to go along with it
in season five so all of that is to say
they did a great job of putting nacho in
a desperate situation and making us
think it could go either way in the end
for him in this trailer there's only a
few other shots with gus and they're
mostly around the chicken farm office we
see him sitting there with folded hands
waiting a burner phone rings on the
table and he turns to look at it there's
another shot of him in that van with
victor and then the two most interesting
things for me is there's a visit with
hector and you do see them shake hands
hector actually looks accepting of
whatever he's there to talk to him about
and then there's also a scene where you
see that someone is surveilling gus's
house it's hard to say what's going on
here this could be at his neighbor's
place or it could be inside his own
place this could be his own people or it
could be law enforcement there's no way
to tell but i'm curious to see what's
happening here and speaking of law
enforcement there was one shot where we
might have seen hank at nachos we see
that someone's using a power tool to
open that safe that we saw mike looking
at and it's not a great shot but i think
it does look like hank speaking of
things from breaking bad we do get a
shot of saul's white cadillac with the
lawyer up plate so he'll be driving
around in that soon and there's also a
shot of him coming up to the giant
inflatable statue of liberty that we
were used to seeing outside of his
office it looks like kim's there with
him there's a mobile home that's painted
like the american flag and then we see
these two looking at the strip mall
office location before he moved in so
all of those things we associated with
saul are falling into place there's also
this life-size saul goodman cutout
that's been thrown into a pool the
clothing and everything looks like
breaking bad aerosol this may have even
been made from a photo from the
promotional materials from that show but
because it's in the water you can't say
for sure i looked at it frame by frame
and can't find anything meaningful out
about where it is or who is pulling it
out of the water we also see a much more
dapper looking spooge from breaking bad
who says to jimmy you're the guy right
jimmy asked what guy is that and he says
salamanca's guy so i wonder if him
paying the all cash bail has made him
somewhat of a celebrity in the criminal
underground or whatever is going on here
when he comes into the nail salon though
we see that he has a lot of new clients
that are waiting to see him and if you
don't remember spooch he robbed skinny
pete with his wife and then jesse had to
go to his house looking for him he ended
up dying being crushed by an atm and
that was attributed to jesse and it came
out that he was one of saul's clients
when he was talking to walter about that
coming back to jimmy and kim there's a
shot of them on the bed where she says
do you ever feel like you're being
followed and he responds while you know
what they say the wicked flee when no
man pursueth that's a proverb about
having to watch your back or being
paranoid because you're doing wrong
things and she asked him if he thinks
they're wicked and right after that the
days of wine and roses by andy williams
starts there's a shot of kim literally
looking over her shoulder and i talked
about it in my last video but she's
wearing this floral print shirt so all
the people who like the theory that
she's gonna run away with lalo got
excited that she might be in mexico and
then there's this one that is perfect
for the tone of the trailer where she's
nervously tapping her foot while she's
wearing high heels this all ties back
into their plans to go after howard
which jimmy was worried that she might
not be thinking it all the way through
as far as what that was going to be like
there's a quick shot of howard's car
pulling up to the crystal palace motel
in a hurry and another one where we see
him finding a small bag of drugs inside
his locker there's also a shot of howard
walking with cliff maine and it looks
like someone's watching them from a
distance in the voice over we hear kim
ask him are you building a case against
jimmy and you see him standing in what
looks like a country club or maybe a
hotel or spa howard responds that he's
just getting warmed up and when i
thought about this i feel like this is
all part of their plan if you think back
to the scams that jimmy pulled by
himself and with marco and then later
with kim there's a lot of getting the
mark to do the thing that you want them
to do in a way that they think it's to
their advantage so i think that any case
howard might be pursuing i mean we know
jimmy is still a lawyer practicing four
years later and breaking bad i think
they're leading him in the direction
they want him to go and then planning to
set their trap it's possible that howard
is just reacting but i like to think
that when they put their plan together
they anticipated how he would respond
because frankly they're in jimmy's
wheelhouse here this is what he's good
at there's a shot of kim smoking a
cigarette i guess since the events of
bagman she just smokes indoors now and
you hear jimmy saying no one knows what
we're doing except for us and that's
followed by some quick shots that flash
on the screen that ends up with a shot
of howard sitting next to a window with
his top button undone he looks kind of
beat and then kim's sitting at the
counter of a restaurant by herself and
you can see that there's a cup of coffee
sitting in front of the empty seat next
to her so there's no turning back
they're all the way in on whatever this
plan is kim's fate hangs in the balance
and it's not the only thing they're
gonna have to deal with because of
course lalo is still out there we don't
see a ton of him in this trailer there's
a shot of him pulling down a bandana
that he was using to conceal his face
then there's this one where you see him
wearing the same shirt he had on in the
season five finale and there's still
blood on the shoulder which means this
is probably right after the shootout in
front of him we see another character
raise his head from a sink and smile it
looks like he was shaving and you can't
help but notice the streak of gray in
the front of his hair in the same place
that lalo has it there's been a lot of
speculation about this character and i
even saw that some people thought it
might be jeff the cab driver from the
gene timeline that isn't the case the
actor has been identified and even if it
wasn't i don't think that's something
that they would have revealed in the
first trailer another popular idea is
that this is a yet unnamed salamanca
it's possible and i guess that could
account for the gray streak in that they
look similar there are definite gaps in
the salamanca family tree remember
hector is tio he's their uncle but
probably the most exciting idea is that
this is a body double or look alike
considering this is happening so close
to the events of the finale this poor
guy might be shaving to make himself
look like lalo only to get whacked and
be used to make it look like gus was
successful in his assassination attempt
the federal police at the crime scene
are respectful of the cousins when they
walk by and it's kind of unrealistic
that people wouldn't know what those
guys do or what lalo and his family do
for that matter maybe they could get
them to agree to make it look like lalo
did die and that would give him the
advantage of gus not knowing that he was
still out there and a threat it's a
little bit crazy though and i do think a
big part of what's gonna happen in gus's
story in this season is he's going to be
battling against lalo whether he's able
to buy some time or not he's definitely
going to be gunning for gus there's no
doubt in his mind who was behind this
attack so something is gonna happen of
course we expect that lalo does die at
least before that conversation that gus
has with hector where he tells him his
whole family's dead but it makes for a
good setup to see how that happens and i
think we can all agree that that is one
of the biggest questions that's out
there so really just a great trailer
gets you excited gets you thinking but
doesn't give anything big away the song
is perfect and man this season is going
to be heavy there's a few shots that
there's no context to that i didn't
touch on a shot of a drain near an
overflowing toilet someone taking a pair
of scissors apart to use one of the
blades and at this point i think i've
probably gone on long enough i do have a
lot more better call saul content coming
soon i'll definitely be covering the
season doing breakdowns of every episode
and before it comes out i'll get more
into speculation and predictions and i
think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you're most excited about what did i
miss did you see something that got you
thinking i think the two things that
jumped out to me the most were the new
character with lalo and and the idea
that howard was trying to start a case
against jimmy but let me know what you
thought please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon